comment est-ce qu'on peut repérer un
jeune qui est en train de se radicaliser
quels sont les signes visibles qui
pourraient alerter leurs proches
surtout pas chercher de signes religieux
de visibilité religieuse ce serait faire
l'amalgamme avec les musulmans et c'est
ce que les extrémistes recherche qu'on
les prennent pour de simples musulmans
orthodoxes qui ont leur liberté de culte
et de conscience donc il faut chercher
les indicateurs de rupture très vite ils
vont isoler le jeune du reste du monde
en lui disant qu'il détient la vérité
qu'il est supérieur au reste du monde
que il a un discernement que les autres
n'ont pas et qu'il ne doit pas
fréquenter ces autres interlocuteurs
le jeune ne va plus fréquentes et ses
anciens amis ont disons qu'ils sont un
pur va arrêter sa guitare et son
football en disant que c'est le diable
va arrêter l'école en disant que ça fait
partie du complot pour endormir les gens
et va avoir une rupture familiale
puisque le groupe va remplacer
l'autorité familiale